welcome to this video playing super
Mouse here from Vietnam right let's
check who that is Lake run long okay
that's not 11 of the Supertop guys okay
than i am but sometimes you have to be
cautious with the IM title because
people almost all of the time register
there there IM tired long as you see
because it gives them the free
membership but sometimes they start with
the with the IM then get the GM turtle
and never actually tell the icc because
it's some it has no financial benefit so
sometimes they're under IM you have very
very strong players that there are
actually GM's okay what to do here maybe
yeah this pressure on h3 is a bit
annoying but i don't need to cancel yet
i still have a couple of useful moves
available Bishop h6 not sure this is one
of the usefulness it is first
job before is a move that I have to have
available trying to get this night into
a tricky spot on age six on a six not
h6e six yeah of course that was possible
what am i doing now to be five maybe
trying to say that the a porn is a
problem for him ok kangaroo gade
actually we're maybe just not afraid ok
it was good and it's just good and 97
well we'll trade stuff very likely
mm-hmm and of ok and after night to a
eight I actually have a problem with my
night I don't have any any square to go
to that's a bit awkward
a night be eight and then a six I have a
493 but it's not not exactly what I want
yeah and then send okay yeah we had
something similar it with had something
similar just a couple of games and go
with black yeah so but now I have 94
actually to go to see three if he goes a
6 may sb5 Scott be fire but ok that's
not a huge deal i can take I don't mind
let's see i have i have some play in the
center here his lights are not very well
positioned here at the moment thinking
93 f4 f5 but maybe i'm just wrong I can
also try to take it Quincy to Bishop f5
like 92 let's see form
and I would like to trade my bouche of
that's a nowit's look strange fit the
ship age 3 is actually a problem because
I have to go now g3 then
I can go f3 though maybe that's okay
Bishop h3 f 3 looks damn ugly but I have
to prevent Quincy form there's no way
around that we should be 4i take on c4
it's not a problem and II 694 also
should be okay maybe I'm not in a bad
bad shape IAM very interesting ticks
ticks nights nights e46 stinks okay
let's do that first oops i always have
94 now to cover g5 very very hard how to
play position nighty for now and before
before it's really happening 96's i
think not as as much of a problem yeah i
don't think i would have come to this
this kind of setup without the game that
i had earlier where I think I didn't
lose I am I as I i won due to this
connection or something like that but he
really killed me there okay let's let's
need 95 check
check on g5 ah good good resource buddy
let's play here but he can go to a
four-eyed I don't have any I don't
really gain from that
you can just go to F form look see 5 DC
5 and I don't see you more dt6 maybe g5
is just hanging night I've not D Phi
here i can try that i cannot actually
huh it's there somewhere here to play
this 95 I need to reply to that move III
maybe the night is hanging there
I don't have to play that's nothing okay
so night g5 i cant i cant cannot check
them Eve III time morning queen at five
and then i have no moves might have to
mean okay i have to have to play the
time is ticking down covering h2 and
stuff age shrieking g3 probably know
it's doing this see threatening h3 you
know what can do here right maybe three
I can take I thought that the endgame
shouldn't be too bad night f2 Queen f5 I
have chances to pick up pawns not
totally sure
Jack doing ah he's got this chick has
got to check them Queen g4 chick how
unfortunate
how unfortunate
yeah again 11 bloody one bloody game
before I get 225 I get one of those and
the guy plays like a check defense this
whole thing like a genius white resigns
ah it's really often yeah you just won
one or two games away from the high
school this is this looks disastrous
it's just a disaster this position how
did you survive this because I didn't
take on d6 ok so that did did win well
it's terrible terribly complicated how
the thing is I didn't see Roxy five if
this is just the problem Luke c5 it's
just the move Queen a form i mean i can
take c5 and draw but i didn't want to
draw out of this position ok i can go 95
here it looks terribly dangerous to play
that magic and their check
that's what the computer gives with wide
winning but good luck and playing that
so I did that here I Queen d2 was good
okay but I was I was really thinking
that this was still interesting h 4f
four check check k look see whenever
this is amazing amazing all of a sudden
I'm falling apart here again one game
short of 25 okay thanks for watching